bonjour j'ai 15 ans et je suis un petit
lapin un petit lapin chez les compagnons
charpentiers c'est l'apprenti car il ya
trente ans de ça et parents ont eu le
courage de me confier aux compagnons
pour qu'ils puissent parfaire son
éducation d'hommes mais également me
transmettre un métier m'apprendra métier
à l'âge de 15 ans j'ai aussi cette
chance de tomber amoureux nous métier de
charpentier
les trente ans plus tard j'ai toujours
cette même passion cette même envie de
le transmettre aux jeunes il ya suez qui
je travaille mais voilà en 1985 devant
les portes de la maison de dijon 1 800
km de chez moi je vais commencer mon
apprentissage de charpentier pendant
deux ans je vais apprendre le b à ba
dans mon métier mais également la vie
copé unique des valeurs ces valeurs que
mes parents m'avaient déjà enseigné
voilà deux ans deux ans ont passé
j'ai un choix à faire est ce que je
désire rentrer chez papa maman avec un
des bus de bagages sur les bras ou de
tenter l'aventuré
je décide de mon compagnon s'ils
accepteraient de m'adopter cette demande
va être accepté par l'ensemble des
compagnons car ce sont tous les corps de
métiers qui vont accepter si oui ou non
je suis capable de partir sur tour de
france nous voilà devenu la coterie
cabon aspirants charpentier breton jeu
pour commencer mon tour de france je
reçois deux fois par an une affectation
à laquelle je me rends faut savoir que
lorsqu'on est sur le tour de france
on n'a pas cherché de travail on n'a pas
à chercher un logement tout ce qui
et repas linge sont également gérés par
les compagnons tout ce qu'on en a à
faire c'est uniquement à prendre comme
tout salarié ont travaillé en entreprise
il y en a cette chance d'avoir tous les
soirs deux heures de cours de 20 heures
à 22 heures également le samedi et
j'avais également un week-end par mois
était réservée à faire des maquettes le
reste de dimanche
on se sent dans son serveur aller
visiter les régions mais voilà déjà
arrivé à la fin de mes cinq ans
d'aspirants j'arrive devant de nouvelles
portes
c'est de la réception que vous devez
connaître comme étant le travail le
chef-d'oeuvre copernic
cette étape par contre une étape qui est
purement corporatives uniquement mon
métier qui va décider si oui ou non je
suis capable
c'est mon métier qui va décider si mon
travail est correcte et c'est également
lui qui va me réceptionné sur mon projet
c'est un projet commun avec trois autres
jeunes aspirants des compagnons devons
donner notre chance ils ont conclu que
le travail était correct et nous ont
reçu compagnon lyonnais la franchise bon
sur la fidélité franc comtois la clé des
coeurs et moi même avons tous un
persévérance pourquoi ce nom de
compagnons et il ya un nom de région
simplement car nos anciens pour ne pas
être fichés par la police avait trouvé
cette astuce de ne plus appeler par leur
nom de province depuis sap et parlant
prénom dans votre famille s'cusez moi
mes parents non de province est une
vertu
ce
by mesure et 17 mètres cinquante de haut
pesée 24 tonnes et servait à signaler
l'arrivée de l'exposition itinérante des
compagnons charpentiers à travers la
france l esprit mais aussi l'évolution
du métier de charpentier à travers les
siècles lorsque l'on ait reçu compagnon
charpentier
on se doit encore trois en trois ans
deux compagnons étudiants qui sont les
plus intéressantes durant ce tour pour
ma part j'ai fini mon tour de france à
berlin en 1996 faut savoir
qu'aujourd'hui on a des points de
passage à travers de la planète gens me
disent souvent que les compagnons sont
une un apprentissage dur compliqué je
peux envie de vous dire c'est plutôt
simple car tous les jeunes qui sont à
l'intérieur
cet apprentissage aucune envie aucune
soif c'est d'apprendre de partager tout
ce qu'ils ont de toujours voir tirer
ceux qui sont avec nous vers le haut si
je devais résumer mon tour de france ont
une phrase ça serait celle ci je ne suis
pas là pour me servir
je ne suis pas là pour asservir jusque
là pour servir mon métier est le
compagnon quelques années pas dû rentrer
en france en 2005 je décide de créer ma
petite entreprise de charpente avec mon
ex épouse pour pouvoir quand
avait pas nuire dans la vie
professionnelle et lorsqu'on devient
patron chez les compagnons on devient un
singe et j'avais également cette envie
de faire transmettre de faire connaître
au métier de charpentier dans la région
de saint-brieuc
car il faut savoir que bon nombre de nos
anciens sont malheureusement partie dans
les tranchées en 14-18 pour y faire les
étaiements et que très peu en sont
revenus il y avait que leur savoir c'est
également le sait même période un
quartier de maisons passives devait se
voir le jour sur la commune de mauguio
lors de réunions préparatoires
ce que je pouvais entendre qui moi me
blesser me faisait mal c'était
d'entendre dire que les artisans
français encore plus breton ne serait
pas capable de réaliser ce genre de
bâtiment
j'ai pris ça comme une gifle car son mon
tour de france on m'a appris une chose
on va après avoir confiance en moi
il ya ce et qui je suis ce n'est pas
tombé qui est important c'est comment se
relève et comment on peut peut insuffler
l'envi à des artisans de se former si on
leur dit on n'aura pas confiance en vous
vous n'êtes pas capable moi qui va de
soi qu'en 2008 quand un projet de maison
passive s'est présenté à nous la
première de bretagne on a répondu
enfonce est ce que je la retrouve
également dans ce projet c'est cette
façon de travailler en union avec les
autres artisans et tous a chapeauté par
un architecte qui était le chef
d'orchestre dia su faire jouer à ces
musiciens qui a su nous emmener pour
qu'ensemble on puisse jouer une belle
mélodie
ce qui m'a aussi plu dans cette maison
passive c'est que j'avais réussi à
allier mon métier la tradition mon
métier et la nouvelle technologie du
bâtiment en 2011 un autre projet s'est
présenté à nous la rénovation d'une
vieille longère bretonne en bâtiment
passif les propres
on trouvait dans cette maison une pierre
datant de 1789
il estime que cette pire n'est pas
d'origine
elle a été récupérée de notre chantier
pour être remis dans la maison ce qui
veut dire quoi c'est qui veut dire que
les anciens savaient déjà faire du
recyclage travailler en filière courte
favoriser l'économie locale chose
qu'aujourd'hui deux cents ans plus tard
on cherche à remettre en place
on va faire maintenant le tour de la
maison
la façade sud est orienté pour capter le
plus de soleil possible plus de calories
possible la façade nord est est non pas
d'ouverture on se protéger des vents
froids et également ne pas voir de
déperdition à l'ouest on a remplacé la
grange par un jardin d'hiver qu'on
appelle une zone tampon dans laquelle on
peut voir sortir de la maison
ce qui n'a pas lieu d'être une zone
chauffer tels que le sellier la
buanderie une chambre d'amis des
toilettes supplémentaires
est ce que j'ai retenu mois de cette
maison quand je la vois à l'extérieur
c'est qu'encore une fois qu'on m'a
appris sur le tour de france
tout était sous nos yeux je fais juste
de regarder d'observer nos anciens
avaient déjà compris qu'il fait pour un
bâtiment ça il fallait simplement
construire logiquement simplement on va
passer
l'intérieur de la maison car pour
l'instant ce que je n'ai pas encore
parlé c'est du système de chauffage dans
ces maisons passives
car n'y a pas de chauffage je passe chez
nous c'est vous on est tous des
chaudières concert de taille normale ou
petit l'hiver quand il fait froid on
sait maison pour pouvoir les réchauffer
il vous suffit d'inviter des amis on
mange une galette ou deux de vol et sid
un peu plus pour certains il ya la fin
de la soirée il fait bon mais le but
essentiel de ces maisons c'est ne pas
perdre calories que nous on n'a fourni
que l'électroménager a fourni et qu'on a
récupéré par l'ensoleillement
pour cela on va mettre en place une très
bonne étanchéité à l'air et on va
contrôler descente hilaire et les
entrées d'air on retrouve la même chose
qu une doudoune 1,12 si vous mettez pas
d'élastiques au poignet l'air va s'y
engouffrer et vous aurez un ressenti de
froid ce qui est très
important c'est de bouger de pouvoir
contrôler les entrées sorties d'air car
le volume derrière de ces maisons et
renouveler douze fois par jour deux fois
plus que deux maisons dites
traditionnelles mais on fait exactement
la même chose
l'air on inspire on expire et on expire
de l'air vicié la différence accès
maisons saxe et la ventilation mécanique
contrôlée
la vmc qui aura ce rôle cette fonction
mais elle va pas simplement extraire
l'air chaud et va renouveler l'air mais
va aussi en capter les calories qu'ils
vont en sortir pour les réinjecter dans
la maison on a également le dernier
point c'est l'étanchéité à l'eau qui
fait aussi partie des tanches élite et
adhère car il faut qu'on puisse laisser
sortir la vapeur de ces maisons il y en
a le bon exemple avec notre peau
notre peau laisse sortir la vapeur ne
laisse pas rentrer c'est un élément qui
est essentiel dans ces bâtiments passifs
ce que disent à chaque fois les clients
quand on va chez eux c'est que il ya un
ressenti qui est pas calculable qui est
pas explicable qui n'est pas chiffrable
c'est le confort qui est liée à
l'intérieur car cette vmc double flux à
aussi ce rôle de renouveler l'air mais
elle va aussi amener un taux
d'hygrométrie constant entre 50 et 60%
ce qui veut dire quoi ce qui veut dire
qu'on aura pas ou très peu de formations
d'acariens donc pas d'allergie et ils
nous disent souvent on va beaucoup moins
chez le docteur vous étendez du linge le
soir le matin il sera sec
vous ouvrez un paquet de biscuits vous
le mettez sur votre table salle à manger
vous ramener trois jours après il sera
sec dans une maison traditionnelle
vous pouvez voir ce ressenti der lourd
pesant le matin chargé en co2 dans ces
maisons passives vous ne l'aurez pas
ce qu'il y a en commun pour moi entre
c'est entre les maisons passives et le
compagnonnage c'est qu'on a tous besoin
d'avoir confiance en soi d'avoir
confiance en l'autre aujourd'hui sur le
territoire
on a des artisans qui savent construire
les maisons passives
mais plus que ça on a des apprentis des
petits lapins à travers tout le
territoire qui ne demande qu'une chose
c'est qu'on soit là pour leur
transmettre un métier pour l'heure dormi
un métier leur donner leur chance
et pourquoi on continue à faire des
maisons qu'ils consomment
quand j'étais lapins les anciens musées
bon en duo lapin pourquoi tu fais mal
alors tu sais bien faire je terminerai
avec cette petite phrase l'énergie la
plus propre et la moins chère est celle
qu'on ne consomme pas merci
[Applaudissements]